hello i'm james murphy and welcome to
part two
of what's new coming in python 3.10
in the last video i discussed everything
relating to type hints
in this video it's everything else most
of what we'll cover in this video
is more or less just quality of life
improvements but there are some new
features
okay let's get started in my video on
data classes
the one thing that i said the data
classes library is lacking
is support for the slots feature
well data classes now support slots nice
they can also now be pretty printed as
far as quality of life improvements
here we go first up is parenthesized
context managers
you can now use parentheses to enclose
context managers
which allows you to put them on multiple
different lines if you so choose
previously you weren't able to do this
because of limitations of the parser
but in python 3.9 the parser was
actually updated to a new kind of parser
the new parser is a little bit more
robust from the old one and it can now
handle
things like this that the old one
couldn't this is especially useful when
you're
using and capturing multiple different
context managers
if you had to put all of these on the
same line or use line continuations
this would be really annoying the next
quality of life
update is a whole bunch of different
better error messages
for instance if you forget a closing
brace python will now tell you
that you didn't close the brace i'm sure
that veteran python programmers are well
aware of what kinds of error messages
you might have gotten if you forgot to
close a brace somewhere
but for new python programmers something
like this can really make it easier to
learn the language
it tells you exactly what went wrong it
can now also tell you about needing
extra parentheses around generator
expressions and arguments
and it can tell you if you forgot a
colon say after an if statement
i've definitely done this one forgetting
to put parentheses around a tuple and a
comprehension
the previous error message was not so
helpful it looks like this person pablo
contributed basically
all these better error messages so thank
you to pablo
did you forget a comma did you forget
some parentheses
did you have a dictionary key with no
value did you use a single equal sign
instead of two
i've never tried to do this but
apparently start expressions are not
allowed in
f strings now i know and the list keeps
going
better errors if your indentation is
messed up
and did you mean suggestions for typos
in attributes or in names
i think these better error messages are
really going to help out newcomers
on the other hand pep 626 about precise
line numbers is going to help
veterans alike those of you that have
spent enough time debugging may have
noticed in the past
that line numbers are not exactly right
all the time
i'm not exactly sure what makes it
happen but it seems to crop
up in multi-line comprehensions and pass
statements
in any case line numbers and debug
statements are going to be
more precise in python 3.10
here's a change that was really hidden
in the details remember my video on how
plus equals is the sharpest corner in
python
well apparently power equals was a
little bit sharper because there was a
bug in its implementation
power equals will now behave the same as
all other augmented assignment
operations like plus equals
and as long as we're down here let's
talk about pep618
adding a strict flag to the zip function
now you can pass strict equals true to a
zip
in order to ensure that all of the
iterables have the same length
if they don't it'll raise an error there
are also some optimizations to existing
features in the language
the most notable one is that they claim
that constructing strings bytes and byte
arrays is now 30 to 40 percent faster
i'm a little skeptical about that one do
some performance tests and let me know
what you find in the comments
the last two things that i wanted to
talk about are two safety features that
have been added to python
python now requires a recent version of
openssl
i think this is a good thing i don't
think you should be using any kind of
out-of-date cryptography software
and the last thing that i wanted to
mention was the new optional encoding
warning
if you're reading or writing text files
you should pretty much always be using
utf-8
but in some operating systems this is
not the default and it is therefore also
not the default in python
this has previously been a huge source
of bugs where one person tries to write
a file
gives it to someone on a usb stick who
tries to read the file
and it doesn't work you can now set this
flag to true
if you want a warning so that you can
see all the places in your codebase
where you don't specify an encoding or
that you're using a binary format
alright that's pretty much the rest of
the stuff that stood out to me on the
change log
if you haven't already be sure to check
out my video on structural pattern
matching
that's really the big feature that was
introduced in 310.
otherwise of course there's a huge
amount of things that change that i
didn't talk about
let me know what your favorite is in the
comments thanks for watching and see you
next time